super g super sportwagen das ultimative
fahrerlebnis 2015 wurden supersportwagen
für vier milliarden pfund verkauft ich
kann mir damit die nase putzen
meine kunden sind stars fußballspieler
musiker schauspieler aber wir sind
diejenigen die damit millionen verdient
ich habe mehr geld verdient als ich
jemals ausgeben könnte geld
immer mich auf schneidet kann kein blut
heraus sondern bleifreiem superbenzin
wie sichern sie sich die
millionengeschäfte ein auto für fahrt
mit der frau und eines für die freundin
das hier ist für die freunde wenn ich
eine dame in autoverkauf wir reden wir
nicht über autos sondern über rote
schuhsohlen ein bett unter der dusche im
jogginganzug
es kostet 500.000 von stahel wenn ein
kunde anruft bin ich bereit
wie schwer ist es sich in der
gnadenlosen welt der supersportwagen zu
behaupten 217.000 ich hab mal eine
million zu viel für einen ferrari
bezahlt
[Musik]
600.000 funk überlegen sie sorgfältig es
ist viel geld
exklusiv bei einer exklusiven option im
herzen londons geht es für einige der
reichsten menschen der welt wie um
einige der begehrtesten autos der welt
650.000 pfund sportwagen händler wie tom
hat lee und sein sohn versuchen hier
schnäppchen zu ergattern verkauft
herzlichen glückwunsch das ist ein
großer spielzeugladen unsere kunden sind
verspielte menschen die besten
supersportwagen händler verdienen
millionen pfund im jahr
wir handeln mit den teuersten sportwagen
der welt
unsere kunden sind reich berühmt und
oder hochadel die elite der elite
[Musik]
der 53 jährige tom hartley gilt als
einer der erfolgreichsten
supersportwagen händler des landes ein
auto verkauften wir zum rekordpreis von
40 millionen dollar der rekord steht
glaube ich nach rom hat ließ zu hause
ist 160.000 quadratmeter großes anwesen
im dhabi
unsere gäste sind jedes mal begeistert
zwei häuser mit je sieben schlafzimmern
ein helikopterlandeplatz und die
vielleicht spektakulärste garage des
landes das auto hatte elton john neu
gekauft ein ferrari 365 gtb 4 berlinetta
boxer für eine viertelmillion fand
gemeinsam mit seinem sohn verkauft haben
hat wie jede woche alte und neue
sportwagen im wert von bis zu vier
millionen pfund ein ferrari 458 spider
mit maßgeschneiderter ausstattung allein
die farbe kostet 9000 pfund das ganze
auto 200.000 fand lamborghini aventador
das wohl begehrteste auto bei den
superreichen 250.000 mit elf jahren
verließ er die schule und widmete sich
seitdem voll dem handel
ich bin besessen vom handel ich kaufe
und verkaufe das ist mein leben ich bin
geschäftemacher
wie schon sein vater gegen karl nicht
auf eine weiterführende schule
dieser bildete ihn stattdessen im
verkaufsraum aus ich saß immer hier und
fragte wer die leute sind was sie
bezahlen würden was der preis sei und
wie viel wir bezahlt hatten
er ist mein vorbild und ich lerne von
ihnen fast alles was ich weiß habe ich
von ihm gelernt
karl ist mitbesitzer des unternehmens
und für den einkauf der supersportwagen
zuständig montagmorgen fliegt nach
schottland um einen ferrari zu kaufen
während vater tom in london den größten
handel des jahres abschließen helfen er
ist ein auto das kostet 12 einhalb
millionen euro der casinobesitzer mister
thomas möchte sportwagen klassiker für
6,5 millionen pfund kaufen
ein ferrari daytona spyder der wird etwa
zwei millionen kosten geld warum kaufen
millionäre diese autos
die alten klassiker werden nicht mehr
gebaut sie sind wie kunstwerke von van
gogh das interesse in china wächst
ebenso in russland und osteuropa
viele interessenten viel geld wenig
angebote es sollte nichts zu günstiges
sein
nein das würde ich auch nicht empfehlen
sechseinhalb millionen handel bleibt aus
tom muss nach besseren autos suchen
[Musik]
supersportwagen sind das ultimative
männerspielzeug und fast alle händler
sind männer
aber ein paar frauen wagen sich in diese
testosteron getriebene welt
der 458 ist verkauft selber amari
verkauft supersportwagen in preston
[Musik]
wir sind sehr gründlich bei der
vorbereitung und reinigen auch stellen
die die meisten anderen händler aus
lassen würden
das klingt sexistisch aber und da zeigt
sich die hand einer frau
es fühlt sich toll an die eine person zu
sein die das klischee bricht und nicht
den regelfall darstellt träum nicht zu
sehr vom auto ja ein zufriedener kunde
kauft hoffentlich am montagnachmittag
einen f12 selber nutzt ihren weiblichen
charme für das geschäft und demonstriert
es mit einem freund in das auto kann man
einfach reinspringen ein spaß gefährt ja
absolut ich betone den lifestyle aspekt
mehr als das fahrzeug an sich hier
herkommt weiß schon aber kaufen will
oder nicht
man lebt nur einmal und du arbeitest ja
auch hart komm schon
sie kaufen an den luxus lifestyle selber
beobachtet mehr und mehr weibliche
kunden
[Musik]
wenn eine dame anruft oder herkommt weiß
sie genau was die bilder frauen haben
einen guten geschmack bei autos wenn ich
eine dame einen autoverkauf wir reden
wir nicht über autos sondern über rote
schuhsohle das selber betreibt das
geschäft mit ihrem mann der einfach an
marie genannt hat teil ihres jobs ist es
meine haare zu machen ist es heute
einfach nach hinten
sie sind seit zwölf jahren verheiratet
und haben zwei kinder
wir sind wie bonnie und clyde ich bin
brad pitt und angelina jolie
dann bin ich angelina jolie ich habe
eine solche leidenschaft für autos und
fasse sie für mein leben gern ich bin
autofanatiker die amis haben große pläne
für einen neuen millionenschweren
verkaufsraum der neue verkaufsraum wird
großartig
die autos kommen verhüllt mit einem
gläsernen aufzug herunter umringt von
vier schönen frauen die das auto dann
auf decken und zur musik um das auto
herum tanzen
was denkt ihre frau über die tänzerinnen
mir doch egal
die genehmigung steht noch aus
am ende streiten sie sich sogar darüber
welchen sportwagen sie gern nach hause
fahren würden porsche
da haben wir drei oder vier selber magna
ihr mann bevorzugt die klassiker was
besonderes was andere denken ist mir
wichtig nehmen wir den rolls royce
meistens hat selber das letzte wort
[Musik]
ein wichtiger tag für sportwagen händler
tom hardy casino besitzer müsste thomas
kommt um weitere autos zu besichtigen
doch wie lebt man im hause hartley das
ist die harte residenz 28 zimmer 1300
quadratmetern sieben schlafzimmer mit
fernseher und soundsystem das heimkino
für unsere unterhaltung
dieser raum hat 250.000 pfund gekostet
meine frau die ich mit 50 vor drei
jahren
heute sehe ich noch jünger
[Musik]
thomas ist da ich würde dir nehmen
einfach schick tomtom hat weiter
sportwagen vermisste thomas gekauft
damit der seinen sechseinhalb millionen
schweren investment-fonds dafür ausgibt
ein nachbau eines ferrari 250 testa
rossa eine million von nach sehr begehrt
wir müssen ihn aber nicht mit verbuchen
es müsste tut sich mit der thomas von
seinem millionen trennen
der unerbittliche aufstieg der
supersportwagen 1 4 milliarden markt
angetrieben vom verlangen in knapp über
3 sekunden von 0 auf 100 zu kommen
selina hat eine ganze garage voller
ferraris einfach so aufregend man muss
sich was kneifen damit man glauben kann
dass die ganzen autos einen wirklich
selbst gehören john mack seinen
sportwagen so sehr dass er im wohnzimmer
steht 208 gtb und hier bewahre ich ihn
auf die hat seinen ferrari in gold
eingehüllt so etwas zu fahren ist ein
ganz besonderes gefühl man hat hart
gearbeitet um sich das auto zu verdienen
wegen steigender nachfrage wollen immer
mehr händler am markt teilnehmen
auch normale autohäuser wittern die
chance auf große gewinne
wie kann ich ihnen helfen
das autohaus big cars verkauft alles vom
fiesta bis zum
der manager hat für den neuen
verkaufsraum jetzt drei sportwagen für
300.000 pfund gekauft
wir expandieren in dem bereich weil die
nachfrage da ist
viele leute verlangen geradezu nach
diesen autos aus dem team von big käufer
die einen supersportwagen gefahren oder
verkauft sie müssen aufholen
ich weiß nicht viel über ferraris das
also noch einiges nachforschen bei den
supersportwagen ist es wie sonst auch
man muss seine ware kennen
das ist noch neu für uns aber irgendwie
muss man ja anfangen
danke dass ihr alle hier seid und stehen
aufregende zeiten bevor es ist eine
große aufgabe normalen provision gibt es
hier einen zusätzlichen bonus 100 pfund
einkaufsgutscheine pro auto
[Musik]
hallo ich bin's kämen
es gibt neuigkeiten autoverkäufer kevin
glaubt einen potenziellen abnehmer zu
kennen
wenn alles gut geht mache ich die
anzahlung fest und alles weitere ergibt
sich gut als geschafft kevins plan geht
auf
der kunde will den audi r8 für 65.000
von erich hof gleich zurück bis dann
neben dem einkaufsgutschein ringt eine
vierstellige provision
das größte geschäft seines lebens wenn
wir die finanzierung regeln können nimmt
er es
1 365 gt c4 von nur 28 gefahr von
hartley verhandelt noch mit mister
thomas der zustand ist atemberaubend für
ein 50 jahre altes auto geht es nicht
besser
50 jahre nehmen wir die 12345 autos ins
paket auf
das ist an diesem es geschafft mister
thomas zu überzeugen sein geld
auszugeben
[Musik]
6,5 millionen für die besprochenen autos
genug geredet
tom hat seine 61 millionen millionären
aber er hat keine zeit zu feiern
von rufen sie an ich bin in den usa habe
aber in europäischen ferrari f40 ferrari
f40 bitte an ihm handelt immer weiter
ich bin nun einmal so hartley ist immer
bereit für ein geschäft jeder zeit im
bett unter der dusche im jogginganzug
bei der massage ganz egal wenn jemand
mit einem angebot anruft bin ich dabei
thomas winter kommt soll sich mehr
entspannen und bekommt regelmäßig
massagen wie geht's gut schön zu hören
aber ich leide an einem aneurysma dass
vier millimeter großes ich würde viel
dafür geben kein anderes meinen kopf zu
haben
aber ich kann es nicht ändern ich muss
ständig daran denken
tomtom soll eine pause vom autohandel
machen
hallo macht den kerl mit dem sls
roadster ein angebot sage ihm wir geben
ihm 170000 futter fern
wir holen ihn morgen ab tom entspann
dich bei der massage ferraris und ich
habe welche gekauft
die einstündige massage beginnt gerade
erst
[Musik]
500.000 von sterling nicht euro nicht
480.000 500.000 nicht 480.000 500.000
vielen dank aber das ist der preis
sie wollen es für 100.000 danke sehr
ganz einfach das war der preis und der
wollte das auto so läuft das nun mal so
handle ich mit autos manche lieben es
andreasen es direkt zum verkaufsraum für
die unterlagen
doch die nicht nur team verdient
millionen mit supersportwagen dia maries
gehören zu den erfolgreichsten händlern
des leides wir verkaufen supersportwagen
also leben wir im super haus tragen
super klamotten und super uhren wir
reden super treffen super leute sind
super
alles muss super sein man muss supermann
sein
so sind hier super ihr haus hat sie
millionen gekostet
das hier war harte arbeit hat lange
gedauert es so hinzubekommen
es steckt voll modernster technologie
man kann das ganze haus fernsteuern
auch die lichter und so das läuft über
ipads und iphones
wir haben überall 3d fernseher
man kann alles in 3d ansehen und die
pollen sind schick das glanzstück ist
sei das hochmoderne küche
wir haben fantastische beleuchtung im
haus scheinwerfer led s ich liebe es
macht die led sei wäre diese küche ein
auto wäre sie der bugatti aller küchen
[Musik]
selber verkauft jede woche super
sportwagen im wert von millionen selber
ist unsere supersportwagen verkäuferin
sie verkauften reiche männer reiche
frauen
sie ist das herz des unternehmens
steckenpferd ist der verkauf am er marie
einkauft das auto hier gehörte rod
stewart kostet coole 1,3 millionen
selber findet er gibt so viel aus ich
zahle manchmal mehr als ich sollte
einmal habe ich eine million zu viel für
einen ferrari ausgegeben da explodierte
sie regelrecht und stellte mich zur rede
heute hat er einen klassischen ferrari
im auge ich bin nicht allzu begeistert
aber gefällt es nicht wenn ich klassiker
kaufen
sie handelt mit modernen alltäglichen
supersportwagen
sie hat also vorbehalte ich halte ihn
auf dem rechten weg
manchmal muss ich ihnen dafür in seine
schranken weisen
selber spricht ein machtwort am kein
ferrari für eine halbe million
der erfolgreiche sportwagen händler tom
hartley hat sich für millionen ein
anwesen gebaut menschen die 50 meter
weiter steht ein zweites einer
identisches anwesen
[Musik]
wie sein vater zahlt die karl millionen
für sein haus meine frauen ich habe viel
davon gestaltet als oberirdische ist von
ihr als retter der erde von mir da steht
es über der bar
hier treffe ich mich mit freunden
wir trinken und feiern gute geschäfte
oder vergessen die schlechten
es ist absolut schalldicht also gibt es
keine beschwerden von den nachbarn oder
von meinem vater nebenan um drei uhr
morgens also kein jetzt ab ins bett
wie seine geschwister verließ karl die
grundschule und stieg in das
familiengeschäft 1
die medien entdeckten die familie
[Applaus]
also ihr seid toll und priscilla ihr
seid die hartley familie und arbeitet im
gleichen unternehmen richtig 7 was
machst du wenn ich von der schule komme
schaue ich im verkaufsraum nach ob ihr
autos gekauft oder verkauft haben
ich kann das kaum ansehen
ich bin sprachlos genug davon
das war einmal das ist lange her
du hast noch ein kind ich war sieben ja
dann traf seine frau mit sie als
teenager mein vater zeigte mir die
errungenschaften des tages und wir
gingen golf spielen holten etwas zu
essen und kamen wieder heim sollen ihre
kinder ihnen folgen
nein sie müssen es nicht
ich würde sagen ich habe ihnen die
möglichkeit gegeben die ihnen zur
verfügung stehenden chancen optimal zu
nutzen und das haben sie getan
durch die ausbildung der hts geriet aber
der abschluss von geschäften sehr stark
in den fokus
ich würde eher sagen ich habe ihnen
beigebracht was sie für das leben
brauchen werden
ich wollte die schule verlassen weil es
sich anfühlte als würde ich dort meine
zeit verschwenden
karl hat vom besten alles über
supersportwagen gelernt jetzt ist er der
einkäufer von weiß genau was er tut
er kauft mehr ein als er verkauft aber
er kann beides wenn es sein muss wegen
seiner krankheit sollte mehr aufgaben am
carl abgeben
die ärzte sagen ich solle meinen
lebensstil anpassen und ich etwas mehr
zurück lehnen
doch das feld tom nicht gerade leicht
ich liebe mein leben
morgens aufzuwachen herausforderungen
alle abenteuer an welcher aber ich mag
glücksspiele und ich gehe gern risiken
hin
wie wäre es mit etwas ruhe vielleicht
eher nicht
[Musik]
schicken sie es mir per mail und
missverständnisse zu vermeiden
ich melde mich dann selber amari kümmert
sich im büro um einen schwierigen kunden
ich verstehe ihre bedenken nicht sie
sagen sie hätten mehr als den
listenpreis bezahlt der ist 87.000 sie
haben 82.000 bezahlt sich färber um das
geschäft kümmert ist er marie mit
verkauf manager lee auf einer auktion
für klassische sportwagen in london alle
farbkombination das gefällt mir
wenn man mich auf schneidet kann kein
blut herauskommt sondern bleifreiem
superbenzin schönes auto selber macht
sich sorgen
marie hat vor jahren eine million zu
viel für einen ferrari gezahlt am marie
macht geschäfte mit dem herzen
ich mache sie mit dem kopf sie hat sich
in einen maserati verliebt der einst
benny von der popgruppe abba gehörte
aber
[Musik]
keiner richtig gummi gummi gummi
nach der entscheidung geben sie etwas
essen
allerdings beginnt die auktion während
des mittagessens 60.000 keine höheren
gebote keine höheren gebote vielen dank
wir haben es verpasst
lasst uns auf dem heimweg aber hören
[Musik]
noch ist nicht aller tage abend
marie verliebt sich in einen alten
ferrari 246 dino gtb in originalfarbe
die know how
diesen will am marie sich sicher
[Musik]
keine weiteren gebote verkauft
ein sack gekauft ganz einfach kein
problem überhaupt nicht mary ist
hochzufrieden
doch nun muss er selber von dem geschäft
überzeugen wir besprechen den
einkaufsprozess weil ich glaube ein auto
passt nicht zu uns sage ich ihm das ich
will keine schlechten geschäfte machen
es ist in originalem tino blau nicht
nachgemacht hat sie etwas als ich blaue
erwähnte fiel fast der hörer aus der
hand
wir brauchen nicht mal was rein stecken
um gewinn zu machen ist ausgeflippt
aber es war die richtige entscheidung
okay wir später alle meine
entscheidungen müssen dem unternehmen
helfen schlechte die es gehen gar nicht
pictures scheint der plan sportwagen zu
verkaufen aufzugehen
das hier ist schon eine klasse für sich
terry und cash sehen sich den ferrari
für 180.000 an der knopf dort
[Musik]
wie geht er aus
sind sie dafür hier
nein wir kaufen einen ford focus
[Musik]
teams jagd noch immer dem sportwagen
verkauf hinterher
kevin hat er scheinbar mehr wird als
nächstes besprechen wir die finanzierung
er hat einen abnehmer für den audi r8
und wartet nun auf den zahlungseingang
gute oder schlechte neuigkeiten keine
wir spannen dich noch etwas auf die
folter
kevin kevin winken 1000 pfund an
provision
der handel muss klappen denn auch eher
dem hat nun einen kandidaten gefunden
gute neuigkeiten bezüglich der
finanzierung
wir konnten den betrag wie gewünscht auf
1099 im monat festlegen
dem hat jemanden für den r8 dabei mein
kunde könnte den zuschlag bekommen
wer zuerst kommt mahlt zuerst gut wir
haben getan was wir konnten das ist kein
weltuntergang allerdings kunde steigt
auch wieder ein kunde ja schön dass du
ihn verkauft weiß nicht aber du bist
raus
nach dem ganzen aufwand hat er es noch
mal durchgerechnet und konnte sich nicht
mehr als 950 im monat leisten gegen sich
nicht aus du bist am zug ich spüre den
roten zu hause hat er in seiner frau
claire und seiner tochter brie sie
gesagt er könne die nächst viel geld
einbringen
[Musik]
und einen schönen urlaub wohin
vielleicht nach florida wegen disneyland
sowas in der richtung in den handel
abschließen und nach disneyland fahren
können
[Musik]
das habt ihr auch film ja sportwagen
händler tom hartley folgt ärztlichem rat
und nimmt eine auszeit
wie tiger woods seine söhne spielen mit
spielen sie besser als sie ja aber das
war nicht immer so
ich werde alt wer kann besser autos
verkaufen
eine gemeine frage so vor der kamera
natürlich papa papa beim autoverkauf mal
der beste autoverkäufer sein will sich
aber in der firma zurücknehmen
[Musik]
verkauft hauptsächlich autos ein
aber heute lässt ihn einen lamborghini
an den geschäftsmann mister right
verkaufen
ok ich lass euch da mal in ruhe kam hält
sich raus
der hat vollausstattung da ist alles
drin
ein auto für fahrten mit der frau und
eines für die freundin
das hier ist für die freundin er ist
gebongt
karl hat den wagen ist white verkauft
noch während des gesprächs bekam kaum
ein besseres angebot an telefon du hast
zahl der 217.000 das ist zu wenig
freundschaftspreis zu billig ich kaufte
den wagen zurück mit aufpreis danke
müsste hp aber ich behalte das auto sie
wollen keine 5000 pfund auf die hand
5000 wären zwar schön aber das ist das
auto für mich das auto steht noch im
verkaufsraum ich biete ihnen 5100 sie
sagen nein
sollte ich es verkaufen wollen werde ich
mich als allererstes an sie wenden
toms plan karl handeln zu lassen war von
kurzer dauer
er kann nicht anders
[Musik]
das hochgefühl nach einem verkauf hält 5
bis 15 sekunden danach will man einen
neuen handel abschließen um dieses
hochgefühl wieder zu bekommen sind sie
süchtig danach können seien ehrlich
gesagt chefverkäufer tut sich schwer
mehr aufgaben an karl abzugeben
gut wirklich gut backe bleibe cars steht
kevins sportwagen verkauf auf der kippe
wir würden es gerne festmachen
ich habe meinem boss gesagt sie kaufen
das auto und jetzt stehe ich ziemlich
blöd mein boss dachte das geschäft wäre
sicher kevin skizziert sich ich hab den
kerl ich satt wir haben hart verhandelt
er wollte es 2000 günstiger eine
garantie auch okay jetzt sagte er es
gebe ein angebot von audi in der gegend
mit einem vorbesitzer mit weniger
fahrleistung
ich bin enttäuscht aber so ist es nun
ich will das auto verkaufen will seine
provision und versucht bis in die
abendstunden den käufer zu überzeugen
nicht
ohne erfolg ist schon ganz schön spät
immer noch nicht verkauft langsam bin
ich so weit dass ich den handel einfach
nur noch abblasen werden
supersportwagen sind nicht das war
absolut nicht ich würde lieber einen
fiesta verkaufen
[Musik]
eine flotte exklusive autos auf dem weg
zum mekka der supersportwagen
tom hat ließ verkaufsraum
[Musik]
jedes jahr lädt der super sportwagen
fans zu einem besuch seiner garage ein
[Musik]
interessieren begann
siegen
tomtom will sich zurücknehmen
die chance für karl der haupt verkäufer
des tages zu sein
hoffen sie auf verkäufe mit etwas glück
geht was wenn die frauen betrunken sind
dürfen ihre männer kaufen was sie wollen
tomtoms frau priscilla weiß wie schwer
es den selbsterklärten verkaufs
wichtigen feld sich zurückzuhalten liegt
wie ist das leben als zum hartz iv rau
je nach tagesform
es gibt hochs und tiefs
wir fahren nicht den urlaub sondern mein
büro wechselt den erdteil alles gut
alles in ordnung
stimmt alles so
corning kümmern sich um die gäste alles
klar
super danke kann lockt sie mit
sportwagen
optisch kann nichts mit dem aventador
mithalten scheckheftgepflegt bei aston
martin einwandfrei der tag geht zur
neige und karl hat noch nichts verkauft
seine pläne gehen nicht auf
[Musik]
babic karls hat kevin nach tagelangen
verhandlungen neuigkeiten
das geld ist da alles ist geregelt
er hat seinen ersten super sportwagen
verkauft für 65.000 pfund gut zufrieden
danke und viel spaß mit dem autor wir
hören von einander
erleichtern endlich ist alles gut fünf
tage harte arbeit aber jetzt ist alles
super dann trage ich erstmal erledigt
kevin bekommt die einkaufsgutscheine und
die provision wenn ich erleichtert
ihm winken tausende von paris geben ihre
gewinne für einen verkaufsraum aus der
sich gerade in bau befindet 75 ferraris
lamborghinis porsches alles erdenkliche
ich mag ja lichter gott ich habe angst
vor der rechnung für die birnen
realities oder was auch immer
hier kann man überall led-lampen hin
das wird super ein paar tage später
trifft er maries blauer ferrari von der
auktion ein
sieh dir die farbe von dem auto an dino
blau eine schöne frau eine alte aber
prächtige klasse frau und an lassen
jetzt muss er seiner frau zeigen die
über den kauf und war als das auto mit
dem transporter kam war sie zum glück
nicht der halo liebling alles gut
ja schön selber sieht sich den kino an
diese autos sind da damit man sie fährt
sie liebt sich um sie kümmert sie sind
kunstwerke wunderschön gefällt hier ja
ich war wegen den klassikern besorgt
aber ist das auto da war ich positiv
überrascht
es ist ein prachtvolles auto und ich
vertraue amaris urteilsvermögen
die investition wird sich lohnen marie
ist aus dem schneider
macht das nicht noch mal was denn autos
ohne absprache kaufen nicht vergessen
[Musik]
feier seiner rehabilitierung machte eine
ausfahrt im blauen ferrari der ferrari
kann sogar acht spur kassetten abspielen
[Musik]
es funktioniert
ok
[Musik]
wie ist es sowas zu fahren ich finde es
einfach fantastisch fast schon
super
[Musik]
kupplung treten drei wochen nach dem
verkauf des supersportwagens hat kevin b
cars verlassen und verkauft bei einem
anderen händler wieder familienwagen wir
können gerne eine testfahrt für sie
arrangieren geld mit supersportwagen zu
verdienen war nicht das richtige für ihn
klar man kann schon gut geld damit
verdienen
aber das ist eben nicht alles
man muss auch glücklich sein genau
supersportwagen sind nichts für mich für
dich vielleicht eher nicht
kevin doch dank der provision fangen sie
trotzdem nach disneyland
bei den hartleys machen sich die
supersportwagen sammler auf den heimweg
sie präsentiert
[Musik]
sie können ihn jederzeit kaufen wenn sie
wollen ich habe ihn im angebot
alles klar karl will beweisen dass auch
er sportwagen verkaufen kann aber dafür
bleiben ihm nur noch wenige minuten
ein pärchen hat über bentley cabrios und
den sl 65 black series geredet sehen
sich die autos gerade an
wie gefallen ihnen und die preise
hoffentlich wird das wasser carl zwei
autos verkaufen
ab ins büro
er verhandelt eine halbe stunde lang
offen
erst jetzt besitzer eines sl 65 black
series und eines bentley gtc ein guter
tag
ein enormes geschäft karl berichtet
seinen vater davon gut gemacht danke bis
morgen dann
karl bekam das erste lob seit langem
aber noch will sein vater das
unternehmen nicht abgeben
er wird nie aufhören er wird nie
aufstehen und sagen es reicht
ich bleib daheim so ist er nicht
es wird noch dauern bis sein vater das
zepter weiter gibt
ich werde immer weiter kaufen und
verkaufen wenn ich den verkaufsraum
irgendwann im sarg verlassen sollen sie
sicher gehen dass ich tot bin und
strecke ich meine hand aus und sage das
angebot steht noch
[Applaus]
[Musik]